is Hannibal star Mads Mikkelsen in Hideo
Kojima's newest project death stranding
the evidence is mounting I'm Tony and
this is your investigative GameSpot news
update we already know death stranding
features the talents of Walking Dead
star Norman Reedus but what about other
actors Kojima tweeted out a photo of a
mysterious motion capture performer you
can't make out who it is but you can
tell they're wearing an orange and gray
hoodie then the Instagram user Jaime
Skeen one took a photo with Mads
Mikkelsen whose outfit totally matched
Kojima's tweet Jaime Skeen one even
claims the actor said he was working on
a game from a Japanese developer Kojima
has also stated in the past that
Mickelson is his favorite actor nothing
is confirmed at this point but the signs
are definitely there death stranding is
headed to ps4 and PC but there's no
release window at this time kojima
previously worked with Kiefer Sutherland
on Metal Gear Solid 5 and now he's cast
Norman Reedus and death stranding so
even if these Mads Mikkelsen rumors
aren't true you can still expect a lot
of talent in the upcoming game to keep
up with all of it you're already in the
right place
Oh